sa fonction la direction son ancienneté
et ses hobbies sa c4 c4 shojaee pouvoir
le retrouver
la retrouver magali n'aura pas tardé à
trouver son parrain en recherche
d'emploi depuis presque un an elle fait
partie des 28 personnes sélectionnées
pour cette job academy
c'est la deuxième année que la société
de restauration et de services sodexo
répond présente
force est de constater qu'à la fin de la
première édition ça s'est super bien
passé avec des retours évidemment des
filhols ça c'est important
très intéressant mais aussi des parrains
et marraines et parrains et les
marraines se sont pris au jeu
la particularité qu'on a c'est vraiment
de faire des binômes individuelles déjà
d'académie qui sont surtout sur du
collectif mais nous on tient vraiment à
ce que un parent accompagnant un filleul
durant quatre mois
accompagnement et coaching voilà ce qui
attend les binômes au cours des
prochains mois une action qui permet
notamment aux salariés de données
d'échanger et de se rendre utile
j'essaierai d'apporter mon vécu en
termes de recherche d'emploi et la façon
aussi de l'entretien mais réseau pour
en faire profiter
mon filleul je croise les doigts
j'espère que ça a apporté plein de
choses et si c'est pas dans quatre mois
ça c'est fort c'est que ce soit dans
quatre mois mais mais déjà voilà avoir
créé du lien en fait je pense que c'est
ce serait se serait en bien parmi les 19
personnes parrainées l'année dernière
par un salarié de sodexo 15 d'entre
elles ont retrouvé un emploi